Watch people die inside.
"Really Felix?
It's not like I've watched your channel for 2 years already
I don't need anymore of that." (Got em)
🤔 🤔 🤔 🤔 🤔
Before this video begins, I have a quick little announcement.
That's right everybody..I'm talking about...the Cam Link...
You don't know what this is?
Basically, what this Cam Link does..it turns any camera, whether it's DSLR or Cam Corder, anyone--any camera that has HDMI output
Plug it in and you got it as a USB to your computer
Hey look! there I am. You can see me live, it's pretty cool.
And..you know? Even on the stream deck
I can hit record right there and it's recording.
HOW COOL IS THAT?! Elgato, check it out. Stream Deck, link in description
Enjoy the video
"shtthfckup" (shut the fuck up)
I will not stand for the cyber bullying D:
Anymore!
This is enough! I am saying NO! (A N G R Y)
#StopCyberB-..whatever (everyone, we have an announcement to make, st-)
I'm gonna wear my favourite sunglasses to protect myself in this video. (swaggy)
Let's review "People Dying On The Inside".
Ok
That's epic
"At that moment she realized how much she hated her job"
She just looks embarrassing, alright?
Embarrassed..that's English.
I want- people- to die!
On the inside
Stop it youtube demonetization
I meant on the inside..it's different
The greatest moment in TV history was when Jamie Oliver showed children how McNuggets are made
and smugly said "Now who would still eat this?" and literally everyone put their hands up and he looked really sad
*laughs*
This is epic style that I was talking about
People being disappointed!
People giving up on p- living!
This is what I want!!!
This is epic!!!
"Politician brutally--" I've seen this.
He doesn't' get dead inside, he gets "Oh yeah" inside. Look at him.
Look at him!
That's an "oh yeah"  inside face
L-listen here..sees it? he goes.."yeah".
He goes "yeah epic style"
Stop wasting my TIME!!
I WANT DEATH!!
Why is it so hard for people to get it? Don't waste my time.
"Roy Moore spokesman finds out you don't have to swear on a Bible to become an elected official"
Judge Moore has also said, uh- that he doesn't think uh- a Muslim member of
See, I don't know who is who here. So, this will be interesting to see who--who
Will have the "dead inside" face.
My bet is on the left one.
I had to swear on a bible
You have to swear on a bible
To be an elected official in the United States of America
He alleges that a Muslim cannot do that ethically
Swearing on the Bible
You don't actually have to swear on a Christian Bible, you can swear on anything, really. You don't know that?
Alright, Ted Crockett-
I don't I- I- I know-
*giggles* That's the face
That's the face I wanna see!
Yay!
Yatta desu ne!! (I did it)
Thank you that was awesome! *whip sound*
Isn't it great to see people suffer?
Pick one, buddy
Is the dog gonna make "I'm dead  inside"?
hAaa a aaah a Aaaaah
hA-- *wheezes*
Did you realize what cover I was doing there? Great.
Hey, in 2 seconds
randomly smile intensely
Oh no. oh no.
I didn't--don't look at me like that. I didn't do nothing
I didn't do nothing!
Oh, it's making me so uncomfortable
You can tell that the look of "dead inside" sometimes when models have to wear something that they don't like.
It's always glasses, it's always like
"Hey can you wear this dumb glasses and smile?"
"Ok!"
Just me?
"A victim of circumstances" Alright, what do we got?
Oh my god, it's the song!
It's the same song I sang. That's the song of "dead inside".
hAaa a aaah a Aaaaah
*laughs*
The best "dead inside" is when you're already dead inside
It's a double dead inside. As I like to call it.
A dead squared inside
It's quite rare but uh- it happens to everyone at least once
Never triple dead inside.
Trying to remove his headset
Oh make it stop..please..this is not epic, guys.
Oh my god, it's still going!! JUST TAKE IT OFF!! OH MY GOD IT'S STILL HAPPENING!! WHY IS IT NOT STOPPING??!
A prime example of why you don't do anything. EVER! cause this might happened.
Do you not understand the risks?
No..is that real?
Oh
Can someone please give the context of this? This is beautiful.
Oh, it's K-Pop performing in North Korea
Robber thinks he's locked in bank
Is it a pull?
Is it
Someone else comes in!
He clearly thought out this crime. Well done!
Beast Mode goes to basic training
Beast mode is off.
Guys. Beast mode is off. Ok?
I don't like this anymore. Turn off the beast mode.
You might think it's cruel here to stand here and review these people suffering
But what you don't understand if that's what you think- is that
I'm suffering with them. Ok?
Finally you understand..that you're not the only one going through these things
It's an endearing thing. Ok?
Teen's mom gets up and dances during baseball game
Why is it that parent's just get off on embarrassing their chi- kids
Why are they so cruel? WHY are you doing this?!
Parents are truly despicable
It's the genuine fear, he's shaking
"WHAT HAVE I DONE?!"
NOOOO!
This--this reddit is beautiful man.
When you show somebody a funny video you've been laughing all day at and you're waiting for them to laugh
JUST LAUGH ALREADY!!
You don't get it.
This is why I don't show videos to thots.
You just don't.
The one male attendee of my mom's wine and painting class
I'm sure he came there on his own free will
Stop judging, okay?
He did a great job on that-- he didn't even finish his painting!!
"When your skateboard trick is almost perfect".
Awww, mannnn.....
"That sucks!"
"Angry girlfriend
You know this has been going on for years, too
He's learned to just block it off completely
For just a moment, he thought about not getting up.
Oh no...
He's like "I would--I would prefer stay..*wheezes* here
"But then I can't breathe".
What do I-- *breaks into laughter*
"Guess I'll die...!"
"He forgets he can't clap"
Why is he clapping? He broke f--what is it?? 3 fingers? His face too like "Ahhh...damn..forgot I can't clap"
I really want to clap right now.
The compulsion to clap with everyone is just too strong
Life truly is cruel.
Yeah.
Here's another "guess I'll die"
When you fall in such an embarrassment way, it's probably better-- just stay down.
You know that expression "you fall off the horse, just get back up"?
Sometimes..just--just stay down..
It's better to stay down.
*loud gasp*
Ooooooohhh. Ohh... Noo....
*laughs*
Did he drop his pho--he dropped his camera..
Oh myy--cuz he threw his stupid water bottle
And then he didn't even get the water bottle
Alright this is it
For "watch people die inside"
I think I just discovered a new hobby! This is great!
Leave a like if you enjoyed watching as well
Thank you guys for watching and see you guys tomorrow with another video
hit SPONsor to join the livestreams
Goodbye